Transcriber: Thekra Alkadee
المدقّق: Nawal Sharabati
يعطيكم ألف عافية ونشكر وجودكم كثيرًا
معنا اليوم لآخر اللقاء إن شاء الله.
جئتُ اليوم حتى أشارك معكم
موضوعًا مهمًا جدًا،
كان لهذا الموضوع تأثير كبير في حياتي،
وبصراحة هذا الموضوع لا يتعلق بي فقط،
يمكن أن يتعلق هذا الموضوع بكثير من الناس
الموجودين معنا اليوم.
لغاية ما قبل أن أكون على خشبة هذ المسرح،
كان من الضروري أن أحدثكم عن موضوع بعنوان،
“كيف تبنون امبراطورية“.
أتعرف عندما تتحدث عن امبراطورية؟
يخطر فورًا على بالك قوة، عظمة،
شيء غير عادي أو طبيعي،
لكن، أتعلمون ماذا؟
قد غيرتُ رأيي.
سأتكلم اليوم معكم عن موضوع
أهم بكثير من هذه الامبراطوريه.
سأشارك معكم اليوم أساس أي امبراطورية.
سأتكلم اليوم عنك أنتَ وعنك أنتِ،
حتى نستطيع الخروج من هذا اللقاء
بأكبر فائدة ممكنة،
بعد إذنكم أريد منكم
أن تركزوا معي مائة في المائة.
لأنه صدقوني الذي يمكن مشاركته معكم اليوم،
من الممكن أن يكون نقطة تحول في حياتكم.
دعني أقول لك أول شيء أن الكرسي
الذي تجلس عليه هو كرسي بمليون دولار،
نعم سيداتي سادتي.
لو أخذت القرار اليوم لتخرج من هذه القاعة،
لتطبق الكلام الذي سمعته،
والذي قلته على خشبة هذا المسرح،
بعد ثلاث سنوات من اليوم،
يمكنك أن تكون قادرًا
على بناء عمل تجاري بقيمة مليون دولار.
هذه هي العظمة وهذه هي الإمبراطورية
الحقيقية التي حضرتُ لأشاركها معكم اليوم.
أنا موجود معكم اليوم لأنني مؤمن
بأن داخل كل واحد فينا ملك أو ملكة.
ولكن القرار بين أيادينا
أن نُخرج هذه العظمة التي بدواخلنا.
خارج هذه القاعة،
95% من العالم هم جنود،
هل أنتم من هؤلاء الجنود؟
أو هل تريدون أن تصبحوا ملوكًا وملكات؟
الحياة مليئة بالتحديات والصعوبات،
ولكن الخبر السار أنه يوجد العديد من الناس
استطاعت أن تتجاوز هذه التحديات والصعوبات.
لذا، هل أتحدث مع ملك أو جندي؟
إلى ملكة أو مجندة؟
مثلما تحدثتُ في البداية،
أن القرار يعتمد عليك مائة في المائة.
يعتمد القرار عليك مائة في المائة،
لأن التحديات والصعوبات
التي يراها بعض الناس معيقات
هي نفسها التحديات والصعوبات
التي من الممكن أن تكون الخطوات والسلّم
الذي يمكن أن يوصلك
إلى أهدافك وإلى قمة القمم.
أتعرفون أنني كنت أتمنى يومًا من الأيام
أن أكون موجودًا مكانكم لأسمع هذا الكلام،
أكون أسمع كلامًا لأشخاصٍ
تساعدني على اكتشاف شغفي،
وتساعدني على اكتشاف ذاتي
وخصوصًا في بداية حياتي.
طول عمري ومنذ كنتُ صغيرًا وأحلامي كبيرة،
والحمد لله حققتُ جزءًا كبيرًا
من هذه الأحلام والأهداف
وما زال عندي أحلام وأهداف
أعمل على تحقيقها.
أعيش اليوم الحياة التي أتمناها،
حيث أسافر متى أريد وإلى المكان الذي أريده.
جئت اليوم كل تلك المسافة
من تركيا إلى فلسطين،
لأقول لك أنك تستطيع
أن تعيش هذه الحياة أيضًا.
أنت أيضًا تستطيع أن تعيش هذه الحياة.
القرار بين يديك،
جئت اليوم لأشارك معكم نصيحة،
هذه النصيحة هي تجربتي الشخصية
من أول ما بدأت حيث أنني في يوم من الأيام،
كنت قد بدأت من الصفر دون أي خبرة.
بالصدفة قد بدأت في عمر الواحد والعشرين،
وانا طالب في الجامعة .
كنتُ أفتشُ على أي فرصة،
كنتُ أفتش على أي باب أمل.
كنتُ أفتش عن أي طوق نجاة
لما تبقى من أحلامي.
في ذاك الوقت، بدأت مشروعًا
يكاد أن يكون من المستحيل النجاح فيه.
بدأتُ العمل عن طريق الإنترنت في عام 2009،
وكان العمل عن طريق الإنترنت من الخيال،
حيث استخدم الناس الإنترنت للتسلية فقط.
في ذاك الوقت،
قررت أن ألتزم وأجتهد،
وأقدم كل شيء أستطيع عمله.
والحمد لله، أكرمني ربي واستطعت شراء سيارة،
وكانت هذه السيارة الهدف الأول بالنسبة لي؛
نوع فيات 127،
(تصفيق)
كانت هدفًا صغيرًا حتى أستطيع الوصول
من بيتي إلى الجامعة بكل بساطة.
لكن أتعرفون ماذا حصل بعدما حققت هذا الهدف؟
أصبح عندي جرأة غريبة،
وأصبحت أقول لماذا لا أحلم؟
ولماذ لا أفكر بشغل أكبر؟
فقررت أن أتجرأ وأحلم في شراء
سيارة مرسيدس جديدة،
وموديل سنتها أي سيارة فخمة
وهذا الشيء الذي قمت بعمله.
فتشتُ على صورة وأحضرتها،
وعلّقنها في غرفة نومي.
في ذلك الوقت، استهزأ العديد
من الناس بحلمي،
وقال العديد من الناس هذا مستحيل،
كان الموضوع بالنسبة إليهم غير منطقي .
كنتُ في بداية مشواري، وبالنسبة لي،
كان لا يهمني آرائهم.
وعندما بلغتُ السابعة والعشرين من عمري،
استطعتُ أن أحول هذه الصورة
من صورة في بيتي
إلى حقيقة موجودة أمام بيتي.
(تصفيق)
استطعتُ تحويل هذه السيارة
من مجرد حلم إلى واقع.
وأكرمني ربنا بعائلة سعيدة، الحمد لله!
وأعطاني ولدين يتحدثان ثلاث لغات بطلاقة،
ويعملان على اللغة الرابعة.
هذا مثال حي أمامكم لكل إنسان لديه حلم،
ولديه هدف ووضع أمامه خطة للعمل عليها،
ووعد نفسه، كما وعد عائلته
أن يقدم لهم الأفضل ولا يقدم لهم أعذارًا.
عندما يبدأ عقلك بالتفكير والتخطيط
فإنك تفكر بالمحيط الذي تعيش فيه،
أي يعني بقدراتك.
لذلك عليك ترتيب احتياجاتك أولًا،
ومن ثم التفكير في أهدافك،
ومن ثم التفكير في أحلامك.
ويهذه الطريقة فأنت توسع آفاقك.
فالأحلام لا تنتهي،
مهما كبرت فإنها لا تنتهي.
في هذه اللحظة، لو تحدثنا مع بيل جيتس،
أو السيد ريتشارد برانسون أو إيلون ماسك،
لهذه اللحظة، ما زال عند هؤلاء الأشخاص
أحلام يعملون عليها،
لهذه اللحظة، لو تحدثنا معهم،
سنجد أن لديهم أفكار مجنونة،
وتتحول الأفكار المجنونة إلى خطة
ومن ثم تتحول إلى شيء واقع.
هذا هو الفرق بين مَن يريد أن يحلم ليلًا،
أو يريد أن يحلم ويخطط لتحقيق حلمه.
لهذا، هذه هي أول نصيحة
سأعطيكم إياها اليوم،
اخرجوا من هذه القاعة وابدأوا
في كتابة أهدافكم أحلامكم.
يمكن أن يؤثر هذا الشيء
على الثلاثين سنة القادمة في حياتك.
ويمكن أن تغير شكل حياتك
في الثلاثين سنة القادمة،
أو أنك تقرر عدم القيام بشيء.
وبذلك ستعيش نفس الحياة بقية عمرك
دون أن يتغير شيء في حياتك.
وتكون الموظف العادي، المهندس، المحاسب،
الشخص العادي الذي يعيش ضمن عائلة فلسطينية،
أو الصورة النمطية العادية
المُعتادين عليها،
أو تقرر أن تكسر هذه الصورة النمطية
وتكون أنت المعرّف لكل شخص يعرفك
من عائلتك أو من أصدقائك .
ويصبح كل شخص يقول،
أنا أعرف ذلك الشخص وهو قريبي.
يحتاج التغيير الحقيقي
في الحياة إلى جرأة وشجاعة،
لهذا، إذا أرت أن تحلم،
فضع معايير وأهداف سامية لتحقيقها،
وأهم شيء لا تنظر
إلى المستقبل بعيون الماضي .
كانت هذه أول نصيحة
أحببتُ مشاركتها معكم اليوم.
أما بالنسبة إلى النقطة الثانية،
يجب بكل بساطة أن يكون لديك قدوة.
لو نظرنا على هذه الصور،
فهي لكريستيانو رونالدو وميسي وصلاح،
مَن هم هؤلاء؟ إنهم أشهر
لاعبي كرة القدم على مستوى العالم
كانوا، وهم صغار، أطفالًا عاديين
يلعبون بالحارة مع أصحابهم أو مع جيرانهم
يذهبون إلى بيوتهم العادية المتواضعة.
الفرق الوحيد أن غرف نومهم
لم يكن لون جدرانها بيضاء مثل غرفتي وغرفتك.
كانت جدرانها مليئة بالصور،
صور لاعبين مشاهير في ذلك الوقت مثل،
روبرتو باجيو ومارادونا وبيله.
الآن، يمكن أن يكون صلاح وميسي ورونالدو
أفضل من هؤلاء اللاعبين في الوقت الحالي.
لكن يحتاج كل واحد فينا في بداية مشواره
إلى شخص يجعل الحياة أجمل.
يحتاج إلى شخص يشجعه.
يحتاج إلى شخص يجيب على كل أسئلته
واستفساراته دون أن ينطق الكلمة.
عندما كان ميسي صغيرًا يلعب في الحارة،
كان الأطفال يستهزأون به،
هل تعرفون لماذا؟
كان قصيرًا وغريب الشكل.
كان يذهب يوميًا إلى البيت
ويتكلم مع صورة مارادونا
واليوم ميسي هو واحد من أنجح
لاعبي كرة القدم على مستوى العالم.
سؤالي لك،
مَن هو قدوتك؟
مَن هو قدوتك؟ تريد أن تصبح مثل مَن؟
ضروري جدًا أن تكون على معرفة بهذا الشخص،
ليس من الضرورة أن تعرفه شخصيًا وتتحدث معه،
لا، لا،لا.
من الضروري أن تعرف قصة هذا الشخص
والتحديات التي مر بها،
لأن تحدياته كانت جزءًا من قصة نجاحه.
الألماس،
لو أرادوا استخراج الألماس من الأرض،
فإنه يتعرض إلى أكبر أنواع الضغط،
وأنت، لن يخرج الألماس
الذي بداخلك  إلا بالضغط.
وعليك تقبّل هذا الشي
أو أن تتقبل أن تعيش حياة عادية.
تذكر شيئًا، الحصول على الشيء الجيد
ليس بحاجة إلى العمل الشاق.
فإذا كنت تبحث عن الشيء العظيم،
فاجعلها تكون رحلة عظمية وجميلة.
اجعلها رحلة جميلة
ومن الضروري أن يكون لديك معلمًا
كان لدى كل واحد من هؤلاء الأبطال
معلمًا في بداياته.
من الممكن أن يكون هذا المعلم والدك ،
أو أي شخص ناجح
في المجال الذي تريد النجاح فيه.
يكون المعلّم بمثابة
جهاز تحديد المواقع العالمي الافتراضي.
حيث كلما تخطىء في الطريق وتخرج عن المسار،
وترجع إلى الجهاز ويصحح لها طريقك.
هذه النقطة الثانية
التي أحببت مشاركتها معكم.
أما بالنسبة إلى النقطة الثالثة والأخيرة،
فبدونها كل ما سبق باطل.
بمعنى لو لم تطبق هذه المعلومة
التي سأتحدث عنها الآن،
فكل ما ذكرناه من قبل لا يعني شيئًا.
يقول علماء الاجتماع
أن أبواب النجاح هي ألف باب،
تستطيع أن تختار الباب الذي تريده
لتنجح في حياتك أو في عملك التجاري.
لكن هناك طريقة واحدة
وبدونها مستحيل لك أن تنجح:
الالتزام.
عندما أحب ربنا أن يختبرنا
في هذه الحياة بالالتزام،
اختبرنا بالصلاة، ووقتها.
لا يجوز أن تصلي العشاء مع الفجر معًا،
وتقول لربنا أنا الليلة أشعر بالنعاس.
لا يحق لك في رمضان أن تفطر
قبل عشر دقائق لانك تشعر بالجوع.
ولا يجوز الاحتفال بعيد الميلاد المجيد
في حزيزان/ يونيو بدل كانون الأول/ديسمبر.
هذا هو الالتزام سيداتي ساداتي،
الالتزام الذي أتكلم عنه اليوم هنا
ليس معناه الالتزام بالوقت.
الالتزام الذي أتكلم عنه اليوم هو الانضباط.
اليوم، لو أردت دخول الجيش،
فأول شيء تتعلمه هو كيفية ترتيب سريرك.
أليس صحيحًا،
وهذا حتى تتعلم الانضباط.
الانضباط يعني فصل مشاعرك عن أفعالك.
إذا أردت أن تكون موظفًا ناجحًا،
عليك الالتزام بساعات دوام محددة،
وعليك التركيز في عملك مائة في المائة.
لو أردت أن تكون لاعب كرة قدم ناجج،
لا يجوز لك في منتصف المباراة أن تقول لهم،
مزاجي ليس جيدًا ولا أريد أن أكمل.
إذا أردتَ أن تكون طالبًا مميزًا،
عليك الالتزام بالمحاضرات
والامتحانات التي تقوم بها.
الانضباط نوعان:
إما انضباط سلبي مراقب من الآخرين،
مثل البصمة التي يذهب إليها الموظفون
يوميًا، هذا مراقب من الآخرين،
مما تجعلك تعمل وتتحرك
لكن لا تسمح لك أن تبدع.
أو الانضباط الإيجابي أي الانضباط الذاتي
الذي فيه أنت الوحيد الذي يحاسب نفسه بنفسه.
هذا الانضباط يكون اتجاه أحلامي وأهدافي.
كان محمد علي كلاي يقول دائمًا،:
" لقد كرهت كل دقيقة من التمرين،
ولكن كنت دائمًا أكرر،
لا تستلم وعاني اليوم
ثم عِش بقية حياتك كاسطورة“.
الانضباط هو مفتاح النجاح،
الانضباط هو عنوان النجاح.
في نهاية خطابي، أريد أن أقول لكم شيئًا،
في كل مشوار حياتكم، وثقوا اللحظات
التي تعيشونها والأماكن التي تزورونها،
وثقوا اللحظات الحلوة واللحظات الصعبة،
لأنه في يوم من الأيام،
يمكن أن تكون متحدثًا
من على هذا المسرح تشارك قصة،
تكون فيها أنت المؤلف وأنت الكاتب،
وأنت الراوي وأنت البطل.
ويكون عنوانها، كيف تبني امبراطورية.
لذلك، فاليوم لديك حلم،
واليوم أنت ملتزم بأحلامك.
تذكروا TEDx المنارة،
اسمي شادي الزوياني ولدي حلم.
اسمي شادي الزوياني وأنا ملتزم بأحلامي.
(تصفيق)
شكرًا لكم.